[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: --was
this fascinating piece
in the news the other
day where they actually
found a cave painting
in an Indonesian island
that is up to 40,000 years old.
It's the oldest cave painting
that's ever been found by man.
Again 40,000 years,
I mean, just the
thought that human
beings have been trying
to exteriorize their minds
and symbolically represent
themselves for 40,000 years,
that the human imagination was
pulsating 40,000
years ago, that there
was enough agitation,
enough of a desire
to transfigurate the
contents from within
and translate them to
the spaces of without
to externalize ourselves to
project, to represent the urge
to represent.
That symbolic capacity of man
has been here for 40,000 years.
I just find that
absolutely mind boggling.
It's one of those things
makes that you wonder-- like,
where does come from?
What awoke it?
What-- it's just one
of those mysteries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]